[Applause]
what do you think was your closest
near-death experience in your whole life
i almost drowned
that was it yeah
really
yeah i thought it would be better than
that i i mean i should be dead
it's pure luck i'm alive i don't think
people realize how close i was to death
yeah i'd still got stood up yeah i
thought you were under maybe like five
seconds no i took a breath of water
i had no more air i went to take a
breath and then water went into my body
mm-hmm
and then you got free well you had a way
washed it free
were you coughing like crazy when you
came up
no i was just i i was weird this is so
weird but like i kept thinking like oh
my god
i can't imagine what
emma's going to think and feel
she's just going to keep looking and
notice i'm not coming up and i kept
playing the scenario of her going
oh [ __ ] like do i go run out there and
get him like how do i get attention
there's only one other guy in the water
like what the [ __ ]
and i kept seeing that play through my
head and then ego kept you alive you're
like yo i don't want anything on [ __ ]
yep drinking all this water
basically yeah i think that was the
closest i don't know what about you guys
what was the closest life or death what
was it like i mean i have a few do you
really yeah what's the closure uh when i
had a gun pointed at my face point bike
range yeah hypothetically you had a gun
pointed at your face hypothetically well
well i don't know if you want to all
right
okay so what happened none it was just
like
two gang rivalry situations stupid [ __ ]
i didn't even have any beef with the guy
he just came up on you no it was like we
were together like group on group okay
and like dude check out a gun and i
happened to be like close to the front
and it was like pointing right at me and
then nothing happened nobody thinks what
did he say what did you say nah it's
like nah we're not taking it there
whatever to chill chill chill it was a
whole bunch of just like chill cho
and then like one person really was like
oh cops are coming and then we all just
ran on both sides it was like chill
chill yeah
yeah
whoa
and why do you think he picked you no i
just i circumstance from where i was
standing
like he would have been pointing at
anybody you were just pointing at the
group and i just happened to be like
right there in front of you
yeah
oh my god yeah okay mark i think my
closest was
driving back from a soccer game i'm not
driving back from a baseball game on the
highway like 12 o'clock at night and
then
two headlights coming at my car
in the opposite direction
on the highway and so literally like
probably six feet of distance like
swerved out of the way like the minivan
almost like flipped like i like felt the
whole [ __ ] like go crazy like all the
[ __ ] in the car flew oh my god and then
i almost swerved out of control and then
just kept driving and then the woman was
in the car like on like off meds or
whatever ended up like crashing into
like the side of the wall and died she
died yeah in that interaction
i mean i didn't later i didn't see it
but it was like half a mile down the
road but like going the wrong direction
on the highway yeah but it wasn't
because you swerved no she was just
going full speed down the highway
oh my god someone like a round of
applause
bro
i guess i mean i if i hit her maybe i
would have stopped her exactly hitting
the wall
so yeah i
you could have slowed her down you
[ __ ] killed her dude i mean
yeah i was in my van van life it was a
it's van life
holy [ __ ] marky landry out here dog this
is crazy
that was good
but yeah and that's a true story coming
back from fort myers
now
did she die because of you swerving or
did she keep driving for a while and
then another she drove for half a mile
and then like the road turned and she
just like swerved off so she didn't even
notice that you were driving right into
her no she was like out of her mind like
debilitated i don't know what whoa
i almost ran into a car straight once
on what on vegas it was a two-way
highway i was going from la to vegas and
you were on the wrong way you definitely
i told you this story right no oh i went
to the left lane because i thought i was
like wow there's way less traffic on
this side right and then
and then
and i was driving straight and like my
friends are kind of like cast out and
one of my friends is next to me in the
uh front seat and he hears me go and
hears me oh
that's weird
he's got white taillights
and then my friend kind of goes huh
yeah it's just weird that guy's white
tail is
i didn't know you could like customize
your tail lights and
and you know if you're both traveling at
70 miles per hour [ __ ] guess
what
quick yeah yeah i mean like so all of a
sudden i was like am i speeding like i'm
catching up to this [ __ ] like oh
my god and he goes bro what the [ __ ] are
you doing and then swerve back into
their lane there's no other cars there
so it was easy it wasn't that close yeah
but
it's shocking how quickly
the cars meet such an idiot but i i was
just i knew nothing about cars both
times oh yeah i didn't even have a
license both times he almost killed
himself
yeah a person tried to attack me a gun
got pointed her head you're your own
worst enemy dude
both times you got to protect you put
myself in this situation
i really did put myself in this
situation that's a great point yeah dude
other life or death experiences i have
another time uh i was in costa rica with
friends and we were like in the town we
weren't in like the
commercial area which uh i don't
remember the town this is uh back in
college okay this was i know we were in
the surf park tamarindo
probably tamara but it was a bunch of
surfers there but um
so we rented atvs and we went out to
like one of the beaches that was a
little bit far away and they told us
like yo you have to get back before
sundown because there's no lights you
won't be able to drive going back or
whatever of course we
stayed later than we were supposed to
and so it's like uh convoy but maybe
like four or five of us all atv and then
we started to get a little bit too far
apart and so the person in the front was
like he stopped so then we could all
regroup and so when we stop
uh
like oh mind you there's like dust
flying up so you really can only see the
person's brake light that's it you're
just following the brake brake lights
off no no you're just following brake
lights oh yeah and so it's like i was
like as long as you're in brake light
you're good
when i stopped
we're on a cliff
my wheel was this far away from the edge
and it was a straight drop down
so had we not stopped maybe like a
couple seconds later i would have been
gone
whoa yeah actually it was wild
and you didn't even notice because it
was so dark no i know i did like you
can't it's pitch black all you see is
just dust and brake lights you didn't
even know you were all near a cliff no
i mean i got another one
right
that's how the segway guy died wait what
happened the guy that founded the segway
died because he was like segwaying
around the cliff and literally drove off
a cliff
yeah just wild son
when i was going to look at colleges in
california this cliff thing makes me it
reminds me all right guys we're going to
take a break from this exclusive patreon
clip because i got to tell you how to
keep your dicks hard and this is how
you're gonna do it with blue
[ __ ] chew i'm telling you your
girl isn't getting the dick she deserves
and that's on you and you can switch
that up same active ingredients that's
inside viagra cialis but this
this is the chew this is the one that we
rock with and this is the one that we
satisfy our loved ones with you got a
side chick you need to satisfy you got a
new girl you haven't even slept with you
got to chew her out you chew it up to
her out okay this is the course of
action bluechew.com you use the promo
code andrew you know what's gonna happen
you're gonna get it for free all you
gotta do is pay five dollar shipping use
that promo code andrew at bluetooth.com
you get it for free all you gotta do is
pay five dollars shipping i'm telling
you this is the truth you deserve the
best and so do the women in your life
now let's get back to this exclusive
patreon clip that you can find the full
episode and more episodes at patreon.com
flagrant2 join the [ __ ] army see you
soon i was going to look at college in
california with my dad and you know the
highways have you driven on like the um
i think it's called like a pch or
something like that it's the highlights
of the coast yeah so it's like it's
right on the water yeah it's fire it's
it's beautiful it's a little more
inconvenient but it's just stunning and
you're like driving along these cliffs
right and these huge cliffs so we
stopped because there's a couple like uh
lookouts right is that like that big
highway in europe that everybody
says
like you can drive really fast oh no no
it's this is not speed like it yeah it's
specifically scenic yeah
on the coast like on the cliff's edge
looking at the water
and you're probably going slower for
that reason you're like let me just look
at this you're at the edge of the world
right and just
hundreds of feet down straight into the
water right
you're dead if you've fallen because
they're just rocks and that kind of [ __ ]
so
i went
to the lookout and then i wanted to go
on the rock part right
and you know how the rock part
essentially it's not just straight like
that it kind of like tilts and then
you're over
so i was on this part right here
and um
i slipped
and once you slip after a certain
gradient
there's nothing you can do yeah you
can't hold on to anything like there's
nothing right there's nothing hold on so
there's no branches nothing it's a slow
slide until your death oh [ __ ] so i
slipped and then i kind of sprawled
because i felt like
if i had like the most surface area
possible it would be harder
for me to continue sliding
and i just slip i just kind of like
spread out
i pick my feet back up and i slowly push
myself back but it was one of my dad
didn't even realize really what was
happening but it was one of those
moments where i was like
[ __ ] like if i
if i was maybe a foot further
there'd be nothing i could do and i
would slowly slide and pick up momentum
until i just fell off the side of the
[ __ ] cliff oh [ __ ] that's great kind
of
am i describing it yeah i'm picturing
you like almost like star star fish yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah inching your way
back yeah
yeah
and you already have a fear of heights
terrified you ever see the videos of the
kids in russia that like hang on off
this edge of the skyscraper so the
chinese kid right the dad doing what
chinese uh there was like a chinese
influencer that was doing a campaign for
something and he had to go off the side
of the
building
and uh i guess they're not the best at
gymnastics
so like he goes off the side of the
building and he's just hanging off the
side of the building that's part of it
yeah
and
something happens where
he's hanging up the side of the building
and he's used to doing it off of a
window or
something but where his feet can't grip
and get enough traction to pull himself
back up so he tries and his feet slip
his feet slip his feet slip and then
he's just hanging there and then runs
out of strength
and you just watch the and then he just
falls off he just lets go
and then just goes falls to his death
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] like that's crazy that's worth
watching if you can get that out no it's
not what it is
i mean you don't see the death part
yeah you see the start of it
it's like spider-man no that's not worth
watching that [ __ ] i can't take it and
[ __ ] like that i don't want to see you
guys struggling for a life is this it no
this is the parkour [ __ ] this [ __ ] is so
dumb to me
oh my god i can't look at it oh my god
i can't oh my god
oh my god
oh my they got fire outfits too yeah
they do
super hypey right like this is the one
white person activity that i think is
kind of lit
like y'all have really stupid [ __ ] and
actually no this is stupid
but it looks lit
all the other stuff yeah i do
surfing camping
[Laughter]
yo these white boys are crazy bro
yo this is wild a lot if you guys are
listening you have to just watch a video
for this part just to see oh my god huh
huh
like it's not worth it
oh
i mean this angle is absolutely
phenomenal mark wants to do this [ __ ]
right now yeah i mean it's kind of far i
would i want to do the heights the
height is too much do this don't do this
the heights is too much
not all right
oh we might have to
i mean it's just insane
oh my god
oh
my god
my balls
oh that was fire that was superfly
all right now we're inside now we're
good right i mean
this is a video game we're watching a
video game
i mean people really did this there's no
way this is all one take
oh oh
that's lit
they definitely got a [ __ ] burnt hole
in their pants though yeah i mean
unfortunately no one went in son that
was lit oh my gosh let's do this
where are we going after this yeah
because it's a parkour yeah we're going
to florida
let's go so you shot the special now you
can get crazy
you get crazy now bro yo i'm with that
man
i'm with that also i just saw the
thumbnail uh everybody go check out
shane gillis's special man
we love shane man shane was great came
out to the taping show support and uh go
check out my man shane great dude and
deserves this success walk through the
fire over a million views we forgot to
mention on the last one but he's coming
on the pod
not either next week or the week after
oh
yeah so what's up i figured we'd blow it
up actually then
let's give him the uh alex jones
treatment yeah we gotta go all the way
sauced up yeah
no okay
uh
but yeah but check him out man he's a
great dude great comic man and uh he
walked through the fire i was telling
him bro i was like listen
now when you start to blow off of this
success
i was like this is the worst
metaphor for it or the worst comparison
but just hear me out like
you know how
mike tyson came back from the rape
like he went to prison for rape yeah
and now he is invincible to anything
because we've
forgiven or accepted or don't believe
that happened
so now there's nothing you could pin on
him
now he can say whatever he wants do
whatever he wants be whoever the [ __ ] he
wants and he's uncancelable because the
worst thing that was stuck on him we've
moved past uh you know what i'm saying
so he's being rebirthed right whereas
like so it's like shane's like we
already
people already thought you were the
worst type of human being and then they
found out who you really are and they're
like oh
now you say any [ __ ] racist joke or
anything people aren't gonna go well see
who is right they're gonna be like no he
was just joking he's actually a really
funny guy we got him wrong so there's
this extreme freedom
that comes with not apologizing your way
back in walking through
the fire and coming out the other end do
you feel there was a moment in your
career where that happened i think that
like
i think i didn't i didn't have like
cancellations and that stuff but i think
i was like labeled by certain people in
wrong ways
and i but i think that by sticking to my
guns and never apologizing for it and
just continue to do the comedy that i
that i do
and then finally releasing comedy and
then all these people who saw me say
wild [ __ ] and then they saw it
justifying the comedy all of a sudden
they started to see me when i said those
things differently yeah and they're like
oh no he ju and people come up to me and
be like bro
once i saw your comedy i started to
understand you want to punish it now i
understand it's just jokes and everybody
gets these jokes and like
i went from a guy who had like the
crazy
labels
to a guy that
from you know all people from different
like cultures walks and life are like
please make fun of our [ __ ] yeah oh wow
right like yeah right by just continuing
to do the thing
that i was doing that is funny so i'm
looking at shane like yeah you are
continuing to do the [ __ ] you do you're
just making [ __ ] up jokes that are
really smart really brilliant and funny
most importantly
and now they get it
yeah
and it's just really cool to see that
happen man i'm stoked for him what up
people you just watch a clip from our
weekly patreon episode you can support
the flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
you